E BACK WITH OUR WORL
THEIR AIR EP
EVERY SIACTODA
THE MOST INTENSEE'
START OFCNRTFOUS IN EASTERN E.
NIC, HOW AREKRAINIANUP FOR THIS
SIVE?
YEAH, MOST PEOPLE
HERE ARE WONDERIS
GOING TO START, WHENS GOTO STAR.
THEY'VE HEARD SOH ABOUT
THEY OBVIOUSLY LOOK AT THESE
DRS COMING FROM , DRONES FED THL
WERE WRITTEN T
N
EN
ALLEGED N ATTEMPT ONPRESIDENT PI
BUTHAT COUNT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THENT HINR
CLOSER.UILDING ATT TIONS.
-HM
N LIVE FIRE TRAINING TO TAKE TR
JUST MILES
ER OWN
>> ].
ep VIDEOOF HIMENCHESDAYSGO [ BL
RUSSIAN TROOR.ON-ENGLISH ]
BE T NT
"TY
F THEM WIT
OUR GRENADES."ENOUO
"YOU CAN D"  SAYS.L THE TIME
TOOPS G EVERYOS
TO THEE IT COULD
PART OF THE BIG FFENSIVE
KR ERTAINLY
AREN'T SIN OF THESE TROOPS IN T
EA
E M-113 THEY'RE H
OF THE TYPE  INFANTR
TRAIN ANDRILLED INTOHESES NEVER.
YOU MUSTY.IF YE NG
>>epte
ON THE F LAVLOSTEAH, I O
FRIENDS.
WHAT TOAY
SYU  YOU.
>> YL CAN DIE IN
FOR ME IT'S NOTHING.
MY
I' A HERO.Y FOR ME.
>>NCHE
BEENRNED
CAMARADERI
THE ONLYUESTION, WHEN?
M- LG THHIGHWAYS OR THBRITISH-ME
HERE, THEY'RE GOINTOW THISCOUNT
PRETTYLOSE.KE
THANK SOING US NOW TS THRAINIANR
UNITEDTES, OKSANBASSADOR, THK R
JOINING US.F LAIMS BY
RUSSIA THAT  NOW
ITTES, IS BEHIND THE
TAE
TIME RUSSIA  LYINGAVE BEEN LYINL
435 DAYS SINCED DO ALL THESE HOA
RA
VED IN
ACK.ONIS
ONW WHETHER
WH UKRAIVE
FOR MORE THA40DEFENDING OUON
TERRITORY.
AND THE RUSSIAN TERRORIST
HO AL
TERRORIST  THEM SINCE FEBRUARY
AND EVERYTHINGE.E JUST SAW OUR
UKG US HOW ELITE
INIAN TR  F FFENSIVE.
VRILU.S. NAT
GRESS DA  TOPIC.
>> BUT STE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS NOT FULL
SUCCESSFUL, THE RUSSIANS ARE E
Y DOES NOT
INITIATE A MANDATORY TION AND S
BSTHIRD-PARTNITION SPL  DELIVER
AND OTHERS, IT WILL BE
AMBASSADOR?Y CHALLENGING FORN EF
DO YOU THINKT'S GOIN BE
UGH FOR RUSSIAN EV
MOVE
WELL, WE HAVE S
FAIN
OFFEE IR
WAR CE THEIR
E THAN
HALFF WH. LIBERATED --  WERT
O TAKEV  DAY
BU HAND, WDODEENEMY.
BRUTASOR
WITH A LOT O
AND WE SY BATHEY'RE CAPABL.EN TN
ONA TLE,HET TO
OUUKCHILDREN.LE, K
SO WE E TIVATED,E
THEM.
TH IS .
RESTORED AND ER EWEAPONS OR DO
>>KRSSIANS ARE OUTOUR
Y'V   TKRAINIILY COMES TO THE N
FOR
HAAN ARRIVED WAY THAT YOU'
ABLEO USE?
>> WELL, WE ARDI
THE CAPABILITIH OUR
U.S. HERE.D CI
LA RAMSTEI
MEETINFOH WE ARE
UL PERSOLL SECRETARY
TESD EVERY  PARTIIN
BUGATHERS MORE THACOUNTRIES NO
TOGETHER WHAT CAN WE DRE.
S THE ITEMS YOU ALREADYE ON TH.
M IN THE IUR
AND SOMEARIL
DISCUSSING.
BUT  D
CAPATINOON
TO DEFENTHE COUNTRY NO
ALSO TO BUILD ENDURING STRENGTF
THL CONTINUE TO BE A
LITICO IS REPORTING THAT
INTAS
ERR THE NT LEAKS
OFY AS U.S.
DOCUMES.I MEAN, IT M SENSE.
I' Y.
YOU WOULDN'T WN A
FEW KEY PEOPLE TKNOW TIME
AND PL PLANNED
THAT THE LEAK DIGE OU.S.-UKRAINE
IPE.INK THE TRUST AND ION BETW
BEFORE
UNDERANLL NEVERT NEITHER WHAT